[Música]
los músculos y las articulaciones se
mueven y se empujan el latido del
corazón se acelera la sangre ruge por
las arterias y las venas durante el
transcurso de un embarazo todos los
órganos del cuerpo cambian iniciados por
una variedad de hormonas estos cambios
comienzan Tan pronto como inicia el
embarazo
pocos días después de la fertilización
el embrión se implanta en el útero
como su ADN no coincide exactamente con
el de la madre el sistema inmunológico
debería teóricamente reconocerlo como un
Invasor atacarlo y destruirlo como lo
haría con bacterias u otros microbios
dañinos Ese es el desafío el sistema
inmunológico de la madre Necesita
proteger a ella y al feto pero no puede
actuar como suele hacerlo lo que pasa no
es tan simple como una disminución de la
respuesta inmune en cambio hay una
interacción compleja que estamos
empezando a entender y que involucra
muchos tipos diferentes de células
inmunes algunas de las cuales parecen
proteger al feto del ataque de otras
células inmunes
el cuerpo también crea en el cuello
uterino un tapón antibacteriano de moco
que mantiene alejados a los gérmenes y
que permanece sellado hasta el parto con
el avance del embarazo el útero se
expande hacia arriba y hacia afuera con
el feto en crecimiento para hacer
espacio las hormonas progesterona y
relaxina les indican a los músculos que
se aflojen los músculos que impulsan
alimentos y desechos por el tracto
digestivo también se relajan y se vuelve
lentos lo que produce estreñimiento los
músculos relajados de la parte superior
del estómago pueden hacer que el ácido
salga al esófago y la garganta lo que
causa acidez y reflujo estos cambios
pueden empeorar las náuseas matutinas
causadas en parte por la hormona gsh y
que también pueden ocurrir en otros
momentos del día a medida que crece el
útero empuja el diafragma el músculo que
expande y contra el pecho con cada
respiración esto limita el alcance del
diafragma
para compensar la progesterona actúa
como estimulante respiratorio y hace
respirar a la embarazada más rápido para
que tanto ella como el bebé obtengan
suficiente oxígeno esto puede producir
en la embarazada una sensación de falta
de aire entre tanto los riñones producen
más eritropoyetina una hormona que
aumenta la producción de glóbulos rojos
[Música]
los riñones retienen agua y sal
adicional en vez de filtrarlas en la
orina para aumentar el volumen de sangre
el volumen de sangre de una embarazada
aumenta en un 50% o más pero también
está un poco diluida porque solo tiene
el 25% más de glóbulos rojos Por lo
general el cuerpo produce glóbulos con
el hierro de nuestra comida pero en el
embarazo el feto también crea su propia
sangre con los nutrientes de la comida
de la madre con lo que quedan menos
hierro y nutrientes para ella el corazón
tiene que trabajar más para bombear toda
esta sangre por el cuerpo y la placenta
la frecuencia cardíaca de una embarazada
aumenta pero no entendemos del todo como
la presión cambia en un embarazo
saludable ya que algunas de las
complicaciones más serias están
relacionadas con el corazón y la presión
arterial
el útero en expansión puede presionar
las venas y causar acumulación de
líquido en piernas y pies si presiona
una vena grande llamada vena cava
inferior podría interferir con la sangre
que vuelve al corazón lo que generaría
una caída de la presión arterial luego
de estar de pie mucho tiempo algunos de
estos cambios comienzan a revertirse
incluso antes del parto como cuando el
feto baja lo que hace disminuir la
presión sobre el diafragma y permite que
la embarazada respire más profundamente
durante el trabajo de parto y el parto
gran parte del exceso de líquido se
pierde cuando se rompe la bolsa
el útero vuelve a encogerse en las
semanas posteriores al nacimiento al
igual que con el resto del cuerpo el
embarazo afecta el cerebro Pero estos
efectos son algunos de los menos
entendidos estudios recientes muestran
diferencias en escáneres cerebrales
después del embarazo y la maternidad
temprana y sugieren que estos cambios
son adaptaciones eso significa que
pueden ayudar con habilidades maternales
como una mayor capacidad para leer
señales faciales de los bebés la falta
de información sobre los efectos del
embarazo en el cerebro muestra una
verdad general casi todas las
investigaciones sobre el embarazo se han
centrado en el feto en lugar de en las
mujeres embarazadas las experiencias del
embarazo varían ampliamente tanto en el
rango de embarazos saludables como en
las complicaciones de salud nuevas
investigaciones nos ayudarán a
comprender Por qué Y a desarrollar
tratamientos efectivos Si fuera
necesario Mientras tanto cada embarazo
es diferente y es importante consultar a
un médico por cualquier pregunta
específica
actualmente se está haciendo un viraje
emocionante a medida que se dedica más
investigación a la asombrosa biología
del embarazo
sabía que los seres humanos son una de
las pocas especies de la tierra que
menstrúan por qué profundice en la
evolución de los periodos con este video
[Música]